hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
another edition of what a need a
youtuber of you here at Abby's kitchen
today I'm gonna be reviewing Caitlyn
shoemakers what 8 in a day in her videos
and her blog she shares a lot of really
great and vegan recipes most of which
are also oil-free and I think gluten
free as well so we're gonna take a
little look at what she's eating for
today just like a coconut milk powder
creamer a picture over here
I do tablespoon of that and then
sometimes I like to keep it plain
sometimes I add a pinch of cardamom
today I decided to add in this other
thing that I have that I need to use up
it's just like a mixture of cacao powder
a little bit of extra matcha powder and
some maca powder so I made that and then
I just fill this with hot water and let
a cool little and then pour in my
blender and blend on high for a minute
and it's nice and frothy and yummy and
delicious and yeah it's just been nice
to switch it up from coffee I still love
coffee but recently I've been diggin the
matcha so love matcha it's basically a
combination of my two BFFs antioxidants
and caffeine and Kaelyn also talks about
adding a supplement that has the
combination of extra matcha cacao and
maca and maca
has become such a trendy superfood
recently early trials have found that it
improves sexual libido potentially so
maybe that's why Kalin's into it a
little about chicka wow wow
however the kind of results have been
conflicting and the support of trials
have been pretty poorly done other
studies have found that makam may
improve mood however this was only seen
in postmenopausal women so we definitely
need some more research to confirm these
outcomes
now matcha on the other hand has a lot
more research to back it up due to its
high antioxidant properties it may help
to protect our cells it may help lower
cholesterol and also some early animal
studies have found that it may help
reduce stress and anxiety so I'm
definitely keeping an eye out for some
more human trials on that the problem is
with these kinds of supplements is that
they often have not even been evaluated
by the FDA so there's not a whole lot
stopping these companies
making claims that their products do
magical things and while things like
mecca and matcha and and cacao are all
generally safe for most people and are
packed with vitamins and minerals
there's no reason to suggest that you
couldn't get a lot of these vitamins and
minerals from food and avoid having to
pay $35 for a bottle of powder
personally I would just stick like with
the matcha it seems like she's just
trying to get rid of it anyways which I
mean we all have a bottle of something
random we bought in haste or somebody
gave to us at one point that we just
kind of feel like we need to get rid of
especially if it cost 35 bucks but yeah
I would probably stick with the macho
cuz that's really where the research
lies or just eat more fruits and
vegetables and your polity good alright
let's take a look at her next drink
because if you don't have lemon water in
your what I eat in a day
are you even a vegan youtuber no I'm
just kidding girl love it I love lemon
water it tastes great it's refreshing
and it's hydrating it's got a lot of
liquids going on and hydration is great
so important so key but yeah I'm really
looking forward to seeing her to
something all right let's have breakfast
it's rich in protein and digestion I
don't really cook with it too often so I
was curious to make one of her recipes
using it it's basically like oatmeal but
instead of oats it's using millet and we
can eat instant pop I know I mean me she
makes good recipes so it's gonna be good
but looks like the sound of like yeah
it's cringe-worthy just had to I just
had to say something cuz that sound of
like stirring through wet millet mmm so
before we get into the full breakfast I
want to quickly flag the comment that
Kaitlyn made about millet being alkaline
we've talked a lot about the alkaline
diet here and the idea that certain
foods are
are acidic and alkaline or neutral and
the alkaline foods are good for
digestion so promoters of the alkaline
diet suggest that you should replace
acidic foods like meat poultry fish
dairy and alcohol with foods that are
more alkaline in nature so fruits
vegetables nuts and legumes by doing
this he will apparently alkalize your
body and improve your health pretty much
in every way imaginable so by
eliminating disease improving digestion
and of course weight loss it sounds
really nice but the reality is there is
no evidence to suggest that the alkaline
diet actually works in fact research
suggests that what we eat whether it's
acidic or alkaline does not impact our
blood pH that is an alkaline or acidic
food will not make our blood more
alkaline or acidic our blood pH is very
well controlled at about 7.4 and
assuming that you have working kidneys
and lungs your body does a really damn
good job at maintaining homeostasis if
it didn't caitlin and pretty much every
other vegan youtuber out there would be
dead just by drinking their lemon water
every single morning there is some
evidence that what you eat can have a
minimal impact on the acidity of your
urine but this is mainly important and
impactful for the treatment of things
like gout and hyperuricemia the reason
why people feel better when they go on
an alkaline diet is because they're
often cutting out a lot of alcohol or
processed meats and things like that and
they're incorporating in more
plant-based foods this is just another
rule that is rooted in basic common
sense let's see how things come together
I still need to take my vitamins and eat
my proof and I just love Chris as a kid
and it has reacquired me to eat prunes
every day because they are really great
at keeping you regular and if you
promise with constipation today some
proof
cheap I got these are the ballpoint in
my grocery store I sell to put them in a
glass jar but I'm traveling myself to
eat five points a day for the next month
okay so first of all that bowl there
looks amazing very instagram-worthy and
of course packed with fiber and
nutrition so I definitely applaud that I
also love that she's talking about
taking care of vitamins that's
definitely the responsible thing to be
talking about as a vegan youtuber she's
being open and transparent that that is
part of her daily routine and let's talk
about those prunes because hey if if I
didn't love talking about regularity and
bowel movements would I even be a
dietitian would I even have an entire
playlist all about poop no and prunes
are one of my favorite poop promoters
they're amazing yes they're great for
promoting regularity and treating or
preventing constipation
they are also nutrient packed full of
iron vitamins k a and B six
now if the prunes are just not enough to
fix your toilet troubles
first of all speak to your doctor make
sure you're getting your hydration in
moving and incorporating a wide range of
fiber rich foods and like I said if you
want to learn about constipation and
bloating and digestion and all that fun
stuff you can check out that toilet talk
series right here no need to search
because I know nobody wants their search
engine history to be all about poop I
get it so you can check it out right
here no one's going to tell anyone
our little secret the more texture to me
just like kind of like still coat but if
you ever had
brown rice flakes so I gluten-free
oatmeal so again that bowl looks
absolutely delicious and I love that
that Caitlyn is talking about you know
the texture and trying to introduce her
viewers to something new and exciting
that she's just discovered millet is
packed with antioxidants and fiber and
we know that fiber has been shown to
help lower blood cholesterol blood
pressure even blood sugars promote
regular
so many important benefits I mean if I
wanted to be nitpicky I'd say hey you
maybe you could add some more protein
into that meal somehow extra healthy
fats I know I saw a little bit of ham
parts on top but ultimately this bowl is
mainly carbohydrates so maybe some nut
butter in there some tahini would be
like amazing swirled in I think but yeah
I think that overall it looks like a
really healthy balanced breakfast I made
my like peach cinnamon smoothie thing
that I posted my last video the recipe
is in the video description there's a
link below it's just like peaches greens
chia seed powder okay so I spoke too
soon
so there's the protein we've got our
protein in our shake we've got some
healthy fats from the chia seed we've
got some veggies
from the greens and some fruit in the
peaches perfectly balanced breakfast
love it alright let's move on to snack
rice cake but I've noticed it's a great
crunchy vessel for a large quantities of
peanut butter and peanut butter rice
cakes are like you know pretty good but
the peanut butter is kind of sticky and
I just feel like it needs a little bit
of a sweet element to it so gently to it
and it's like nostalgia for me excited
see PBJs all the time so funny she said
that about rice cakes because I feel
like if weight watchers was a single
food it would be a rice cake it's
basically all of the 90s worst diets
have come together in one food it would
be a dry plain rice cake I mean for the
love of all that is holy whatever you do
do not eat a plain dry rice cake that is
just torture but
like his style Caitlyn because I feel
like if anything's gonna make a race
cake more edible its PB&J like PB&J is
life I need a shirt that says PD and J
is life all right let's look at dinner
[Music]
that looks so good now I'm like totally
craving tofu but I love that she's got
the kind of crispy air fried tofu there
for the protein she's got lots of
vegetables tons of colorful vegetables
we've got the kind of fried rice it
really has all the components of a
really well-balanced meal I also love
that it's totally accessible and easy to
pull off I mean as beautiful as it looks
all of those ingredients are easily
found at any grocery store there's
nothing there that was super expensive
or hard to make or hard to find so I
love it now we get dessert love it
I want s'mores all day long and I
totally want to hit up that recipe so
I'm definitely gonna be checking that
out because s'mores anything is amazing
so yeah that was Kaitlyn's day pretty
easygoing let's take a look at the
macros so Kaitlin is consuming about
2,100 calories 23% of which is coming
from fat 62% from carbs and 15% from
protein she's also getting about 45
grams of fiber because I know she talked
a lot about regularity that's clearly of
importance to her as it should be all of
us I mean who likes being constipated
not me so I think she's doing a great
job on that so let's first talk about
what I like about Kaitlyn's day number
one is Caitlin's simple easy recipes so
I love that Kaelyn really does try to
make veganism approachable basically all
of the recipes here are really easy to
pull off mainly using just ingredients
that you have in your fridge and pantry
with the exception of course up some of
those supplements which it seems to me
like she was just trying to kind of use
them up anyways I really liked that her
snacks
literally minutes to prepare and they're
really just assembly style so ultimately
when a lot of us are in a rush we don't
want to have to make a whole complex
recipe for a snack so I love the
assembly style snacks I also love that
she takes a time to really kind of
educate her audience so for example when
she was trying millet for the first time
she kind of takes her viewers on a bit
of a journey with her and explains the
texture explains some of the different
kind of preparations that she wants to
explore with it so I found it really was
quite entertaining and educational as
well and secondly I love that she
promotes a balanced vegan diet so I
really like and appreciate that Kaelin
ultimately is eating enough unlike I
think a lot of youtubers out there who
promote the false idea that a kind of
grown woman can sustain herself on a
very low amount of calories I mean if
you are a grown-ass woman
you need a grown-ass amount of calories
hard stop from a diet quality
perspective I would say her diet is rich
in fiber it's got lots of healthy fats
also lots of plant-based protein and
after looking at her micronutrient
distribution I would say that she was a
little bit low in vitamin D E and b12
however not surprisingly that's very
common and very likely that she's
meeting those needs with the vitamin
supplement she took in the morning she
also discloses to her viewers that she's
taking vitamin supplementation which as
you know what I've talked about this
before I really just think is the
responsible thing to do as a youtuber as
for what I think that Caitlyn can
improve on honestly not a whole lot
stood out to me I think that what she's
doing is great and the information that
she's sharing is really valuable and
mainly just want to caution the overuse
of these kind of nutritional buzzwords
so nonchalantly so what the alkaline
diet for example that diet has been
severely disputed and ultimately
debunked so of course millet may help
with digestion because of its high fiber
content and there's no harm and of
course mentioning that it's not because
it's being alkalized and therefore has
some magical benefits in conclusion I'm
a big fan of Caitlyn I think that she
promotes a kind of vegan lifestyle
that's very accessible her
ESPYs look delicious they're
well-balanced her diet is adequate which
is amazing sure she does kind of drop a
few nutritional buzzwords or promote
dietary supplements that have limited
evidence however in general I think that
she is a real asset to the vegan YouTube
community and I'm definitely gonna keep
watching so guys I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
any youtubers that you want me to review
I'm constantly adding them to the list
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye